fire and fury in the heart of the city
for the third night in a row a crowd of
mostly younger people chanting these
streets will always be ours until the
anger erupted out of control
some taunting the police who in turn
responded quickly as they attempted to
disperse the crowds the tension in the
Catalan region is at an all-time high
following the sentencing of nine
pro-independence politicians and
activists for sedition over their roles
in the 2017 illegal referendum in an
attempt to calm the situation Spain's
Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez made this
appeal to the Catalan leader in
Catalunya even Unity personas millions
of people live in Catalunya and they
have the right to live securely and in
peace with the right to their own
political ideas but that is incompatible
with the conduct of violent groups that
put at risk the peace of their cities
the property of their neighbors and the
safety of citizens earlier it had begun
as a grassroots protest civil
disobedience to distinguish the real
turn this evening as people gathered in
one of the main avenues here to throw
toilet paper all over the street the
problem is is that there has been a fine
line in the past couple of days between
that kind of activity and violence where
the jailed Catalan politician's
condemned the use of violent tactics the
Catalan President King thought I came
under criticism for failing to call out
the behavior of the rioters his focus
instead the road towards independence we
came to shore support for these marches
that are taking place in Catalonia to
reject the sentence and to support our
right to self-determination and civil
social and political rights endangered
by this sentence
the issue of secession has long hung
over the region it goes to the heart of
people's identities here but it is also
a deeply political question and with
next month's general elections ahead all
sides will be vying for voters rather
than resolving the catalan question so
nigahiga al jazeera Barcelona